كما دهنت الفصائل الفلسطينيه اقتحام وزير
الان القومي الاسرائيلي المسجد الاقصى
واعتبرته استفزازا غير مقبولا ينظر بعواقب
وخيمه
في غزه الفلسطينيين في الضفه والداخل الى
شد الرحال الى القدس لابشال مشروعي تهويد
المدينه
تمثل تصعيدا خطيرا واستفزازا لمشاعر شعبا
الفلسطيني والامه العربيه والاسلاميه
ينذر بحرب دينيه في المنطقه
ثانيا الاحتلال الصهيوني يتحمل كامل
المسؤوليه انت داعيات اصراره في العدوان
على شعبنا الفلسطيني
والمقدسات الاسلاميه والمسيحيه وخاصه تسلل
المجرم المتطرف بن كبير المسجد الاقصى
ثالثا ندعوا ابناء شعبنا في القدس والظفه
والداخل المحتل الى شد الرحال للمسجد
الاقصى المبارك وتكثيف الرباط فيه
لافشال المخططات التلموديه الصهيونيه